Okay.
I've got a great series of clips for you from
Fox news here.
Tucker Carlson, who is I mentioned, has said
that white supremacy is a hoax, said that
immigrants make our country dirtier.
He also said he believes Michelle Obama is
someone that could get into the 2020 democratic
primary race and maybe actually win.
So Fox news host, bill Hemmer brought on a
guy named Michael Blake.
Michael Blake is the vice chair of the DNC.
He's also a New York state assemblyman.
And Michael Blake immediately went in on Tucker
Carlson and also on Fox news.
This is, this is just brilliant execution.
Um, he was asked by bill Hemmer is Tucker's
prediction right?
Might Michelle Obama be about to get into
this race?
And Michael Blake goes full in on, why is
Tucker still on this network?
He said white supremacy is a host.
Bill Hemmer is a hoax.
Bill Hemmer immediately tries to shut it down.
We know that Fox didn't like it when Shep
Smith criticized Tucker Carlson.
Tucker must be protected and this is just
a pleasure to watch.
Hello Bama.
Let's be honest, is one of the only people
who could unite the parties.
Warring factions, Tucker crowds, who are the
bold predictions saying Michelle Obama just
may be the democratic ticket next year despite
the former first lady saying she's not interested.
Michael Blake, vice chair of the DNC and a
New York state assemblyman.
How you doing Mike?
Nice to see you.
Sarah, what do you think of the prediction
on Michelle Obama?
Like to see that.
Well, she's not running, but the core question
is why the hell does tuck a car still have
a job here in the first place?
The reality is this is someone who said white
supremacy is a hoax.
And why does Fox allow him to still be here
in the first place?
Well, I mean his opinion there is that Michelle
Obama may get in this race.
Do you think that will happen or it's not
going to happen?
Not going to happen, but I think the core
question is he shouldn't be on here at all.
We didn't bring you on to talk about Tucker
Kraus and I brought John to talk about the
democratic field.
I love how bill Hemmer says you aren't on
here to talk about Tucker.
He kind of is.
You played a clip of Tucker and then said,
please respond to what Tucker said.
This continued and bill Hemmer getting even
more visibly angry about all of this.
We're talking about jobs while Trump is ignoring
the truth.
We're talking about healthcare, why he's ignoring
And the question must be for Donald Trump,
for Fox news, for other entities, [inaudible]
bash our network.
So with all due respect, why don't we just
keep it on topic, but it's not.
Political magazine says it's just out.
No, it's not.
It is not relevant to the conversation we're
having.
I just, I really relish how furious bill Hemmer
is getting.
Maybe because he could get in trouble for
allowing a guest to do this.
Is that a possibility here?
Really well done by Michael Blake.
I would be shocked if he's invited back on
Fox news.
One thing that you don't, you know, there's,
this is an interesting thing.
There's this unspoken understanding between
Fox news and left wing guests, democratic
guests, progressive guests, which is you can
criticize at the right in your role as the
lefty that we're inviting onto.
Give an opinion, but you're not supposed to
go after Fox news the few times that a guest
has really done it.
It's not welcomed.
It's, it's quite the opposite.
In fact, and Michael Blake ignored that unspoken
rule and just did it good for him.
Absolutely love it.
I'd be shocked if we ever see him on Fox news
again.